past two weeks holiday wishes came true
for a Henderson School Community it's a
charter school and it's made a new
holiday tradition to give the presents
and Grant the wishes that students ask
for Ryan Matthews shows us what they
wish for and the significant students
say it has
while the world waits for Santa's sleigh
I wish for airpod pros
and I received airpod Pros the students
at Pinecrest Academy Sloan Canyon
already got what's on their wish list
it's stuff that like people will
probably remember for like a really long
time the new campus which has served K
through 12th graders for the past three
years started a new tradition last year
they call it winter wishes I wish for a
giant gummy horn school officials ask
what students and staff wish for and
Grant them we got to sit back in the
conference room and then they got us
pizza and soda and we just chilled and
we did have to have the loud boys
outline for real bro from small wishes
like a school lunch with friends
to large ones many never thought would
become real my cat died a few years ago
and I was really sad
so I wish for a cast stuffed animal but
they got me a cat instead I was very
very emotional wishes like those are
what school officials say will keep this
program coming back year after year
thanks to fundraisers and donations from
the local community they've continued
that celebration Friday night for this
drive-through display for a program that
may have more significance to some
students than others that's we're a new
campus so we want to have things that
really our students identify with and it
really does benefit
families and children that maybe don't
have everything that they need and for
our kids to have that hope and that
Christmas spirit that's what it's all
about the magic